texas congressional candidate dan
crenshaw lost an eye to an ied in
afghanistan on saturday actor pete
davidson mocked him as one of the quote
really gross people running for office
this year he said
added i'm sorry i know he lost his eye
in war or
whatever
yeah so that's their position and
they're not hiding it anymore useful for
you to know the more i think about it
takes a lot of gall for eye patch mccain
to attack moms who worry about baby
formula as quote pro russia i mean
that's probably one that's one of the
most outrageous things i think i've ever
heard now that i'm thinking about i mean
why not just answer the question why why
the attacks what does that tell you this
is tucker carlson the flip flopper 2018
tucker carlson goes on the defensive and
says oh pete davidson is is a is a
terrible person for making fun of dan
crenshaw the joke was he reminds him of
a hitman from a porno that was the joke
that that was that was that was pete
davis p davidson went through a list on
weekend update and was talking about
different candidates that were running
for the republican party in the
primaries and when dan crenshaw came up
he said oh it reminds me of a hitman
from a porno you have uh tucker carlson
getting all butt hurt and saying that
snl is making fun of him and then you
get tucker cross in 2022 where he's like
oh he's eye patch mccain so you know
just to go to show you that tucker carls
is not who he says he is he doesn't
believe what you all think he believes
in he will say what he says because it's
an entertainment show it is not
news and once again tucker carlson
flip-flops more than i don't know mitch
mcconnell hmm
surely tucker carlson doesn't have
flip-flopping views and i bet i would
almost bet that dan crenshaw if you
looked at enough clip which i'm going to
have one right here um also also doesn't
have flip-flopping views
i mean dan crenshaw obviously he's
telling the truth about the baby filming
a story because that's the true story is
you can't buy something that doesn't
exist and money isn't going to make it
manufacture even more i think dan
crenshaw's making a very good political
calculation here that the country is not
going to be backing putin and they're
not going to be backing politicians that
back putin and that's why tucker's
pissed at him and that's why he has
tulsi gabbard on who is a russian asset
to sycophant for putin against putin's
enemy which is dan crenshaw who tells
the truth that he's a murderous [ __ ]
dictator i mean if you're against putin
you're against tucker if you say
anything that goes against what tucker
carlson is preaching tucker carlson is
gonna come after you because putin says
i'm gonna release my hounds and
obviously tucker carlson is you know
putin tv it is it is russian tv it is
propaganda so of course he's gonna bring
people on like tulsi gabbard and kane
would be the first one
that to tell uh tucker to go to [ __ ]
hell right and that and that probably is
why tucker hates mccain hates crenshaw
now um he loves dulce gabbard obviously
he's had her on his show like six times
the last two weeks oh yeah and he's like
yeah you're gonna talk putin let's talk
putin let me do that let's see that who
knows a putin puppet better than another
putin puppet right that's true
you